what is a hate mo property and should
you buy one HMO property is a house in
multiple occupancy it's when you rent
out a property room by room instead of
just renting out to a family so my name
is Samuel Letts I've been investing in
property now for over ten years
I started off my very first house
believe it or not was HMO property which
I bought when I was a teenager I then
started buying more properties I've had
single let's flats I have more recently
been doing development I've been buying
pieces of land building houses I
recently bought a castle so I kind of
know what it talks about when it comes
to property investment and I want to
talk about HMOs in this video because
it's what got me a lot of my wealth and
hey cha Mo's was what got me financially
free because when you rent out a
property on a room-by-room basis what
happens is one house instead of getting
one rent you suddenly from one house get
multiple rents which means that from a
cash flow perspective you the property
investor you the landlords are much
better off that's what it is so what are
the pros and cons should you do it one
of the things you need to look for so I
say there's five things when you're
buying a Chan know that you need to look
for the first thing is this you need a
property that's going to need just going
to be able to be rented out by the room
if it's a small little to bed house with
one reception room will it work for a
HMO probably not but it possibly could
because you've got a you've got to have
an eye for changing the use let me give
you an example people think or HMO you
know it needs to be a big property or
maybe I'm gonna need to look for big
detached houses with big drives and big
gardens and I need to search for five
bed only not necessarily see if you've
got a to bed terraced house but in that
property there's two reception rooms
potentially you could rent out each room
and then the reception rooms
you could also rent out as bedrooms the
question is how do you convert a
reception room into a bedroom well
you've got to have the I you've got to
be able to see is this reception room
part of the kitchen and and by looking
at it obviously this couldn't be a bed
or is it separated off with its own door
its own windows if so the way to turn a
reception room into a bedroom is I don't
mean to oversimplify this but it's to
put a bed in it a lot of builders over
complicate this you know they've got
school you want to turn it into a
bedroom listen you just put a better now
if you've got a sitting room with a
really we've aged sofa in it that's the
sitting room right but if you take the
sofa route and you put a bed in there
it's a bedroom so you need at least four
letter ballrooms so the first thing you
need to do is you need to think
creatively and you to look for how many
rooms could you get in this now the
rooms will need to be a certain size
they'll need to be 100 squared feet
unless there's a communal area in which
case they'll need to be 70 squared feet
and to do that
you will not need a license you'll not
need planning permission unless it
happens to be in a particular area that
has article 4 so always Google in fact
this is number 2 I'm going stumble to
you right now
number 2 is you need to check the
licensing and the legality rules of the
area you're looking at so there are
rules around hecho Mo's if there's four
rooms in a HMO you will not need a
license if there's five or more people
in your property renting off you you
will need a license that's a general
rule of thumb but you need to check the
rules in your area and how do you check
the rules you go to a very special web
site called or you can write this down
gee oh oh gee you're Google ok leave is
Google HMO rules in and put the area it
will come up with the license rules in
your area also article four that's
another thing this is by the way point
number two is a little bit meaty so you
might need to watch this again and take
good notes rules hmmm rules if there's
article 4 in your area you'll need
planning permission to change the use of
a single let property into a HMO if
there's no article 4 in the area then
you will not need planning permission
unless there's seven people in the HMO
or more those are the rules I've just
given you a crash course on hmm rules
but if you're unsure go to Google and
you'll be able to find the rules in your
area that's point number two point
number three is if you want to buy a
property and use it as a HMO it means to
be in a
area whereby there are people and things
and jobs and universities and
translations this will not work in a
little village in Wales people think
just because the house might lend itself
well to being HMO the house isn't
everything
sometimes location location location is
correct you do need more than location
four point three is check the area find
out if there's demand in the area for
rooms and you can check that by going to
spare room code at UK which is a website
where tenants that are looking for rooms
advertise themselves and say hey I'm
looking for a room and you can see how
many people have been listed today or in
the last month how many people are
looking for rooms in your area and you
can check that on spare room code at UK
however my general advice is if it's a
city centre if there's a university if
there's jobs train stations and things
around
Sharp's shopping centre if it's within a
mile from that you will be able to rent
it out room by the room they'll
definitely be demand number four is
price he still needs you like anybody
late you need to look at the return on
investment don't think that just because
the area is really really high demand
for rooms like to say like London for
instance oh wow I could rent the rooms
out really fast in London yeah you could
but you've got to look at the rent in
relation to the house prices you still
need to be getting a good return on
investment and the crazy thing is about
HMOs is generally speaking across the
country certainly in England and even
the UK room prices are pretty much the
same wherever you go they tend to be
about four to five hundred pounds per
room if you're in somewhere really cheap
like stoke-on-trent where you can buy a
house for 90 grand or if you're in so
we're really expensive like Bristol
where you buy the same house for
probably half a million pounds the room
rent won't be that much different so
there's no direct correlation between
the house price and the room rents
because generally speaking if you're
looking for a room you're not from the
area you're probably moving in for a new
job you're relocating you're just
finished University so your budget is
the same so always make sure point
number four that you're getting the
highest return on investment you
possibly can which leads me to point 5
and point five is
make sure that when you buy a hey chamo
you've got a hmm management company this
is the big con two HMOs right now okay
the big con one of the cons is the rules
it can be a little bit complicated to
understand which we've covered in point
20.5 is managing an HMO can be pretty
tough and it's kind of obvious because
if you've got a property that's got five
ten minutes in it surely it's going to
be five times as hard to manage because
there's five tenants there's five
tendencies going on whereas we have a
normal property you've got one tenancy
so while you're getting paid a lot more
and you're getting five lots of rent
instead of one lot of rent it is going
to come with more complications with the
management also HMO tenants will tend to
stay for a less period of time a typical
average ten in a house might stay for a
few years
whereas moving into a hey CH mo they
might only stay on average between six
and twelve months they can stand much
longer but so the turnaround is higher
so get a good HMO management company how
do you find a good hmm management
company there's three ways number one is
referrals number two is Google just
Google HMO manager in number three is
spare room
go on spare room and instead of looking
for the people that are looking for
rooms look at the rooms available look
at the ones that are advertised with
agencies phone the agencies and say I
see that you're renting rooms act can
you manage my rooms too those are the
five things that you need to look for
within HMOs or I hope you found this
video helpful if you have let me know by
smashing the like button also drop a
nice comment in the comment section I
read every single one and of course
subscribe to the channel you can
subscribe right here and if you want to
learn more about HMOs as well in the
description link I'm going to be running
a webinar real soon put your details in
and you'll be the first to know about
when the next webinars coming up put
your details in the description link
subscribe I'll see you next time